gentlemen I really want to start with a
congratulations you guys did made such
an exceptional film and I have tons of
questions but before we get into that I
have a few uh let's just say curveballs
to start things off for both of you if
someone has actually never seen anything
you've done before what is the first
thing you'd like them watching and why
well in that case that will be the first
film I'm in I think you should start
from there uh and which called Pusher
Pusher one so that's from 9 99 95 I
believe yeah uh being a director I will
always say watch the last film I've I've
done because you always as a director
usually sort of hate the all the other
movies you do like when and see them in
a perspective of oh my God I was so
young I didn't know what I was doing so
I would always say Watch the watch the
last film I did no matter which film it
is I've heard that from from other
directors if for both of you if you
could get the finance dancing to make
anything you want tomorrow what is the
thing you'd like to make and why oh yeah
I mean I don't know can you can you
bring Bruce Lee back from the
dead does how much money does that take
I like I like to be in a film with Bruce
Lee and B Keon
yeah I don't know what the film is about
but it's going to be great I I actually
I want to do a followup to that because
right now behind the scenes there's a
lot of people selling their likeness
rights because of what's going on with
AI and at some point in the not so
distant future what you just said is
actually possible so does that frighten
you or if someone came to you and said
with AI and computers we can literally
make this movie would you be interested
in it
no no I know I I want to meet Bruce
Lee ke I got it I mean there are
perspectives that that's interesting and
for certain kind of films obviously the
big Blockbuster let's say Marvel
Fantastic films there there are certain
things that you can get away with if you
want to jump in time have somebody who's
20 years old and then 80 uh I think
within the realm of of still being
creative you can do something
interesting but just giving your image
away is I don't think any anyone wants
to be part of that so did you figure out
what You' make if you could get the
financing for anything I don't know man
I think probably some sci-fi Mo like in
Denmark the but don't have big budgets
uh it's where the money is quite small
but uh I I do have a dream of one day
making a sci-fi movie and I think that
but that's going to be hard on a Danish
budget but maybe I'll try one day why
you're looking at me I don't know cuz if
are you in it Mass you want to be paid
if I can get you to star in it maybe
it'll be easier to finance you
know I am curious what do you think
would surprise and maybe you've sort of
just answered it but what do you think
would surprise people to learn about
making movies in in Denmark and in
Hollywood well yeah obviously the
budget um and also the amount of people
uh in Denmark you say good morning to 15
people and in America you say good
morning to three or 400 right uh and uh
so that's a difference um in terms I
mean for me it's a different thing as an
actor you go in into that world you you
find a parameters of of of the framework
of what we're doing there might be a JRE
in there and and try to to make it as
honest as possible within that world so
um I can't call the director in the
middle of the night the same way I can
call
Nick which I you told me not to but I
still did at some point you have to
sleep you know um but besides that we we
will enter a world that is pretty much
the same it's just a different different
um relationship you have with each other
for a director I believe it's a very
different thing yeah yeah for a director
it's very different there's there's a
couple of reasons first of all when I'm
making movies in Denmark it's very much
my work I have Final Cut I have final
say it's my vision from top to bottom
and from beginning to end and I've done
one film here let's not speak too much
of that uh which was not my film it
ended up being something I I didn't have
you know really power to sort of like
make I mean it it was a lot there was
just a lot of decision makers everybody
wants to make a good movie
but if you're like aund shifts on the
same thing it's very hard I especially
coming from a Danish background of the
old tour Cinema it's very hard to find
your footing in that system I felt at
least uh mad's individual question for
you I am a really big fan just like
everyone in the room of your work I
think you're an exceptional actor and
I'm just curious when you are getting
ready to film say the promised land um
how early on are you thinking about the
character prior to the first day of film
and thinking about what you want to do
how much are you sort of doing a lot
towards the end like could you sort of
take us through your process a little
bit on getting ready for a role well I I
get invited in on on different stages in
in um in different films in in American
Film it's it's it's written it's over
it's done uh say the words don't uh
don't uh knock over the furniture and
you're fine right um here in Denmark is
a different thing I I'm invited in when
this story is almost done and then we
start talking and we develop they do
listen to me and I can have some inputs
and sometimes they say well that's a bad
idea but I will insist and we can go
back and
forth um then on the first day of
shooting it's very interesting because I
think about it all the time it's a
gradual development of the character I'm
always curious why are we going to shoot
the first day because the first day is
very important for everyone obviously
for the direct everybody thinking about
it we're not we're not going to shoot
the most difficult scene the first day
but what he might think is not a super
difficult thing can be a very difficult
scene for my character can be somewhere
I I haven't really found yet maybe it's
just nice to see him do some walking
first you know H so so I'm always
curious but it's it's a challenge and
I'll take it up every time Donald
Sutherland told me something that I
found fascinating he said that he now
demands that the first day to a filming
he is filming things from the middle of
the movie because that way by then the
people have bought into what I'm selling
and I can figure it out and you know
what I mean yeah that's smart yeah he's
a smart man I when he said it to me I'm
like this is brilliant you know so let
me ask you another followup on acting
say you have a very emotional or
dramatic scene on a Monday morning and
you know it's going to it's a challenge
it's going to it's you know you got a
pull uh to deliver what you are trying
to do how much how how far before Monday
morning when you're going to film are
you thinking about that scene is it
months early is it at the beginning of
the shoot or is it like you know over
the weekend you are really in it
hopefully we've addressed that scene
long time ago so we know what it's about
we know where we want to go
approximately if I overthink it two
months before I'm going to strangle that
scene I won't even I won't have the
balls to go there at all it has to be a
a a know a natural gradual development
of the film so when that scene pops up
we shouldn't be afraid of it we should
be ready for it but we shouldn't over
prepare for it having said that if it's
5: in the morning I will I will get up 1
in the morning and and get ready I mean
I'm not going to go straight into the
scene but but I don't think you you
should overthink stuff I mean if we if
we touched upon it we're on the same
page don't strangle it let it be a a
natural development jumping into why I
get to talk to you guys uh for this a
little generic but for both of you what
was it about this material that said I
need to make this for me it was uh I
just it's a novel this is an adaptation
of a novel uh and and it was just
reading the novel and just falling in
love with the characters I think the
first character I fell in love with
sorry Mas but that was not your
character that was uh the character and
my moose the little
girl oh yeah anyway so the the girl the
little girl she was the one I fell in
love with first and then came uh
somebody else I don't remember and then
maybe you but phone I'm kidding of
course but I but I also saw I saw a very
personal it was personal to me because
it's it's it's a film about uh and a
very ambitious guy who finds out very
late in life that there's something else
to life other than his Ambitions and his
drive and I've had that same tra
trajectory I'm sorry that's a hard word
when you're not English speaking uh I
had my first uh child when three years
years ago which is quite late I'm 51 so
it wasn't until that happened that I
realized oh my God that's a whole
another world and it's kind of the same
thing that uh Ludwick experiences in the
movie so to me it was reading something
that felt like close to my heart well I
I just got a offered theart so I I
didn't I didn't know I didn't read the
the book um for me it was a pitch and
then it was a script and from there on
we start working um I don't have much to
add I mean did
I don't I can't tell the big difference
working with Nick uh was it 10 years ago
and
now but then again I can there is
definitely a different kind of focus I
mean we were younger there was a lot of
energy in that film and I think we were
approaching it with the same
professional eyes but I there's
definitely something happened with what
the focus of the story is because of
obviously you having kids you guys the
film is uh on the short list for best
International feature uh which is a huge
honor what what does it mean to both of
you to actually have so many people
loving this movie and for it to be you
know shortlisted it's always great to be
recognized it's always great but the the
greatest thing about it is that the
reason we make these films is for people
to go watch them right that's the main
reason so all this sort of uh all that's
going on around the short list and the
film film festivals and everything it it
it it is really helps uh people to
notice that it's coming and they see it
and they so for me that's really what
it's about it's getting the film out to
as many people as possible yeah it it it
is that's the main goal uh and but at
the same time you have to understand
that that's like thousands of films
every year coming out and that that
somebody out there thinks that we are
worthy of being among the 15 films that
might be nominated for an um an oska is
it's incredible it's incredible it's
mind-blowing and we're Danish I mean
we're just happy we're just happy that
somebody watch are country of yeah
exactly at what point though was it was
it the script phase was it when you were
shooting or when it was in post
production that you both realized wait a
minute this might be a pretty special
movie I didn't re I I never realized I
I'm was so uh self-critical but I've
been on every single film I've done and
I never realized with what I've done
until somebody else until I see it with
an audience the first time really
honestly and but for this I think it was
our our co-writer anos Thomas who's
quite a cynical guy I would say and when
he went in to see a cut he came out with
tears in his eyes like oh my God we have
something here because he was actually
moved by it and and he usually is not so
that was that was the that was the that
was the point for me where I realized it
might be a decent film yeah I I it felt
good it all it felt good all all through
uh and then had a few scenes with a
little girl you just watched
it she's what we she's just Priceless
and and and I remember there was a scene
I mean you you can feel a certain way
and it doesn't turn out that way that's
that's often the case for an actor uh
but then I was having a little
discussion with you we just sh scene
where the all the the fields are on fire
and she's running around doing stuff
and and I was looking at the monitor
which I never do I never watch anything
we're doing and I just saw this amazing
workout dop was doing and I thought we
were just jumping around with some
flames in the background it was just
insane to watch and that's why I felt
like maybe we're on to something here
yeah when you looked at the shooting
schedule for both of you what was a day
that you had circled in terms of how the
f are we going to do this or um I can't
wait to shoot this for me and because of
the budget constraints uh I think we had
about $7 million to make this film every
single day was like oh my God how are we
even going to do this so literally
almost every day it was like there's no
way like the fire scene and the snow and
the rain and the things and every day is
like trying to achieve something that
has scope with very little money somehow
so that was the that was but but I
always look forward to to these things
because it's a great challenge but
really what I enjoy the most and always
have are the small intimate scenes uh
between the actors so I was always
looking forward to these sort of like
more milit dramatic if you would say the
dramatic scenes between just maybe you
and Amanda who plays and barara or you
and Molina who plays and Mamu and
especially the scenes between you and uh
Simon who play shingle I was looking
forward to those scenes a lot yeah I was
looking forward to to all scenes but I
was all all also looking forward to the
scenes where we we had the budget in
mind which is always fun uh because that
reminds me of the first times we were
shooting when we had a budget of let's
say
$200,000 and we just made a feature film
right like The Pusher films and and this
was the case always like okay so the the
goat we just killed that is full of
blood now can we somehow clean it up and
have it in the background from the next
shot you know that that's the way you
have you have to all everybody has to
work together to make this work because
it's that's the kind of budget right so
I'm fascinated by the editing process
because it's where it all comes together
so how did this film possibly change in
the editing room in ways you did not
expect there was one big thing cuz I I
had told myself that I didn't want to
make an overlong film and it's I mean
it's 2 hours long so it's already long
enough but at one point it was 3 hours
and something in the editing room I
really had to cut something so and this
is not something I usually would say to
an audience who's just seen the film but
there were certain things that we did
cut out there was a story there was a
lot more story with the priest for
instance who became a smaller character
there were certain things things with uh
with the idle the noble woman uh who
which we caught and and uh in general we
just try to um to make it you know not
sort of like we try to trim the fat in
general and not make it sort of like
self-indulgent and and and I I think
that's also uh part of what you said
we're different uh 10 years ago I would
have probably been a little bit more in
love with oh look at the wonderful work
we've done let's just keep that scene
going for 10 minutes and now I'm much
more sort of like no we we will service
the story uh no matter what cost so well
well I'm still like 10 years ago I like
films that are four hours
long but but I do get it I mean they
shouldn't listen to me occasionally they
should but but I'm I'm the one who says
no no no no no no it's it's fine I mean
for me a 4-Hour film can feel fast and a
and a film that's one and a half hour
long can feel like very very long if it
works it works um I think they had the
the right mixer do you remember what was
the last thing you cut out before you
picture locked oh God that's so specific
yeah I do I do remember that was a scene
with the priest actually that was a
scene with a priest where he where
ludvik and the priest are walking around
the the the the in the heath and trying
to find a spot uh for lud to build uh
the house so yeah that was probably the
last scene that we caught which was I
think 3 days before a picture log yeah
are you a fan of like extended Cuts or
are you sort of like for example with
this you have a lot of deleted scenes is
it something that you want to show
people or you sort of like the theatric
cut is the movie The theatric cut is the
movie but there will be an Extended Cut
but that's purely for I think streaming
an hour a year from now uh we have a
sort of like a a longer version going
into the the streaming something and
it's going to be called the
priest the priest and the and and the
potatoes yeah
yeah sounds like a thrilling movie uh no
I am a fan I actually always watch the
director's Cuts even if they're a little
worse than the theatrical Cuts because I
always like to I'm fascinated by the
stuff that they thought would work even
you know what that they had in the
script I I love that uh mads I'm curious
when was the last time the night before
the first day of filming you were scared
shitless about what you were about to
step into on set like was there a role
that you were really nervous about uh
right before filming
began no I
mean things that doesn't work on paper
will always scare the out of you
right um scenes that that are difficult
and and and maybe emotional or very
physical but a
right uh they they don't scare you as
much as scenes that doesn't work scene
that doesn't works and you haven't come
to an agreement with your director you
just know what the day is going to be
like it's just going to be uphill battle
and and and and that can scare me uh
waking up maybe with a with a with a
pain in your back and doing Flying Kung
Fu can also scare
you I I tend not to be super afraid of
things I I tend to like grab it by the
root and if there's something that
bothers me and will make me afraid
eventually I will pick up the phone and
and and and and meet up with the people
and say let's let's fix this or make me
comfortable something is not working
here so so that's how I approach it I'm
about to open it up to the audience but
one last thing for you guys uh I've
spoken to a lot of actors and they talk
about how they really like doing a lot
of takes spoken to directors they really
like doing a lot of takes and some
actors like a take or two and they just
want to move on so for both of you how
many takes do you typically like to do
on a movie and how many takes are you at
what point do you start saying okay come
on or do you enjoy doing just like a few
takes we're completely in sync I think
yeah we always do like two takes yeah
with mess but that's with you mess cuz
you're so precise and you can do the two
takes and then you're good and maybe
I'll ask for a third take right if
there's something that I'll ask for a
fifth take if it doesn't work I mean
that's there no rules yeah if if we're
almost there then you can see in his
face that yeah yeah okay moving on
moving on then you go whoa whoa no no no
that's something let's just make one
more this is not working I mean and you
you can tell you can tell when it's not
working there's a little more in there
right but often and you ask most
directors and most actors first or
second take there's what we call in
Denmark that the butterfly dust is there
there's a certain unknown territory
uh that if we do too much it will be all
over rehearsed right so often the first
and the second take there are some magic
in them
yeah definitely but but then of course
there's the there's when you then we
also had to do a lot whenever we did a
scene with the the girl Molina who plays
an my moose we did 30
takes cuz she would never remember any
of her lines and like and it was
constantly like no but yeah she's a
child right and she's never done
anything before she speaks Swedish and
not Danish yeah so she barely understood
what I was trying to direct her you know
and and what we were looking for was
like something supernal I mean just
really natural from her and and uh and
that came if we just kept going and she
just got fed up with the words she came
up with something else that was
absolutely fantastic and then and then
that's where we we went for a few times
yeah yeah there the do do you guys
remember when she at one point the the
little bit in the film where everybody's
happy and she goes like
pancakes that wasn't any that was just
something she did that was just like
literally she was so happy that we had
given her real pancak pancakes that's
right and I was like that's great we're
going to use that exactly does anyone in
the audience oh I think I found it I
think I think there were a few questions
we'll start right there Hi my name is
Eden um I just want to say amazing film
I really enjoyed it thought it was so
great um uh my question is just uh
what's your favorite thing about working
together and is there something that
maybe working together like that
challenges you a little bit I love every
second of working with mass like well
dto dto yeah so that's answer no I mean
we worked 10 years ago and that always a
risk that you and since then we' become
friends uh and then he didn't call me
for 10 years for some reason and and uh
but there you always tell that story but
you know it's not well you called me
because you wanted to you know borrow my
bicycle or
something there's always a risk when you
know each other other well that that you
just open the drawer and you do what
you're used to but if you push each
other a little there's there's also the
benefit of like we might dare tread on
territories that we wouldn't dare To
Tread on with somebody else and that
that's the benefit of knowing each other
really well um was that the question
yeah yeah yeah I mean CH with so so I
guess the answer is there weren't a lot
of challenges I mean we we we do
challenge each other a lot we certainly
will not get into fights but we
certainly like try to push each other to
both be better you know at at whatever
or or get somewhere where sometimes
we'll get stuck with the scene and we go
like something's missing what is it
we'll go into a discussion about it but
the beauty of knowing each other so well
is that it becomes a very easy
conversation and there's no awkward like
oh I wonder if he doesn't like me you
know it's just like whatever we can say
anything so when am I going to get my
bike
back
um I think that the the trust thing
there's a very good example in this film
the trust thing because we always we
obviously dealing with
um circumstances coming from outside
that is making this guy's life difficult
and and Barbara's life and the little
girl everybody's life is difficult but
at the same time we also dealing with a
with a person a character who's creating
his own problems I mean there's plenty
of times he could have turned left
instead of turning right you know so if
you just turn left now you can shape
your story everything will be beautiful
but he is so stubborn so he's creating
the his own drama and the trust that
we're talking about here is that that
that was in there in this in the first
version of the story I thought it could
be much more at a certain point Nikolai
had a hun it could but maybe we
shouldn't go there too much because we
don't want to lose sympathy but then he
trusts me to say
listen well we'll we'll get it back home
somehow just you know we'll get it back
home in this scene and that's trust like
okay okay let him be somebody we dislike
for 68 pages and then it happens and
that's trust and and so so so I think
that was a very important part of the
story originally and also in in the
script uh but we might not have gone so
far with the character if we didn't
trust each other yeah yeah we you
definitely helped enhance that part and
made me courageous in terms of not
trying to immediately create an a
character that we identify with but it's
more sort of like hard to actually love
which which really works so well for the
film uh before we get to the next
question but show hands who has a
question I'm just going to see something
okay so this is what I'd like to do
because your answers are great we we
we'll we'll be short however that was
you know was great long answer but we're
going to bring it down so we can get
through a lot more people and we're
going to go right there someone else
we're gonna go right there question for
both of you love the film uh I'm a
teacher I'm going to Denmark for the
first time this year know very little
about it anything either of you would
recommend I do
t t Gardens that's always a winner and
I've heard the potatoes are really
good if you ever grown anything before
you did a lot of cultivating in this you
ever actually grown anything
or actually uh my father-in-law who's
now passed away he grew potatoes and I
did help him for a couple of Seasons so
I knew a little about it he was better
than me no I'm going to go oh wow I'm
going to start right there um thank you
both for being here I love the movie and
I just wanted to ask maass um so what
was it like preparing for uh the scene
where lud gets tortured by um shinkle
and his henchman and um it's LV is such
a um stoic character and yet he's going
through this intense brutal uh emotional
and physical experience so what is it
like to how do you approach that is that
different from other scenes
it's it's a little it's a strange thing
obviously because I'm not getting
whipped in real life
sorry um so so there's a timing thing
going on there so there a technical
thing we have to get out of the way so
if we're both in the frame I somehow
have to know exactly when it hits and we
find a way that we have something that I
can
feel uh but then it's just super cold
and it's just like staying there it's
just super annoying my knees are hurting
we're doing it for hours and uh stay in
there and eventually you just want to
get out of the situation and
and imagining something like that is is
what we do we we're professional
imaginers or Liars or whatever and and
it's just diving there and everybody
hates you the guys who are killing you
the guy who's who's a baron it's just um
it's a lonely and you want to you want
to keep your face so you're holding it
in for a while and eventually you can't
right so I don't know how to approach
that it's just sometimes it's just in
the room you can just feel the Menace
and just go with it right there Hi um a
movie with amazing X um I was wondering
I watched a movie Arctic too and I was
wondering is this movie more physically
challenging or is what was your most
physically challenging Arctic you talked
about a film called Arctic yeah where
I'm at the stranded at the
Arctic uh that that was definitely more
challenging in the sense that um here
when the wind was blowing it was cold uh
but we had a
trailer over there and we can get some
food that did not happen in Arctic it
was Far Far Away it hours away and when
we got injured which we did all the time
just suck it up like nobody's coming you
know um and and and and here is your
food for the day all right great so that
that was brutal really brutal
um and physically right uh but but this
was also I mean I'm I'm what am I 8
years older than I was when I did Arctic
so it it was probably on the same level
if you do like right there uh first of
all it is wonderful to be in this space
with both of you artists thank you
um H well also Leif till I die well done
Theif yeah okay
cool uh but what inspires you both to do
what you do easy for me
it's people like Nick for me I I have
the advantage of being the kid who never
grew up I I am a professional I I run
around and get opportunities to do
things that nobody else allowed to I
ride a horse I have a super cool hawk on
my arm I'm flying through the air in a
in a kung fu
fight so I'm just waiting for people to
have a vision and a dream to come along
and and if if I like that dream it
becomes my dream so this is what keeps
me going it's meeting people like Nick
or meeting nick uh and and see the
flames in their eyes and and then it it
Flames me as well and it's like let's go
I'm surprised considering he has your
bicycle and what's what's your
reason uh I just I I love I just love
storytelling and I don't know where it
comes from it's like playing with making
movies with my Star Wars figures when I
was seven and just going from there it's
been no looking back I don't know where
it came from I just love telling stories
I I know we're we we're towards the end
of the Q&A I know that you guys are cool
with a few more right sure yeah um I
have not gone to the back and I want to
make sure I we're going to come back I
promise as long as right over
there yes hi thank you so much great M
everything you do I want to know why you
Chang the title from the title so well
in this movie why we change the title
from the bastard to The Promise Land the
uh uh us uh Distributors felt it was a
little negative I think
uh and the the and and and on certain
levels I didn't understand it because I
love the title the bastard on another
level I did in Denmark the bastard only
means an illegitimate son so it doesn't
mean a dick you know it just it just
means like an illegitimate son so I
understand that the negative connotation
might have made people think the film
was about something else than it was
yeah right there I I
I okay we come from Mexico my daughter
is love
you love you and she makes a a little
thing for you and what you second it's a
in Mexico is so um exciting for pop to
give to you this one
and was cry because he want
to you that one I love you so
[Applause]
much I love it I Hon a great question I
honestly love
it right here uh Nick this is I believe
your sixth time working with the
cinematographer rosmus I I said it right
um right what your movie was shot
beautifully what problems did you have
or trying to figure out Solutions of
filming in such a empty area for nature
right the the sixth the question was
this the sixth time I've worked with the
same DP I I've never worked with any
other DP than this guy and and there was
not a lot of problems on this one cuz he
he had he has grown so much like he was
already great on our first film but he's
such a great DP that and he knows my
brain so well because we've known each
other since we were in our 20s so I had
very little uh he he was just like he
was amazing you know and every single
setup we were doing he he surpassed my
dreams you know of what what could be
possible on a budget that we have so I
would say no challenge at all it was
just a
wonderful his work is Fant fantastic in
this it really is um right over there
yeah I want to mention that someone's
birthday today they came to see
you happy birthday happy birthday and
second I would like to uh ask about the
weather conditions how much preparation
went into it was it a hindrance was it a
help from the past and the weather
here's here's a funny anecdote about the
weather because when you're working on a
budget like we had you don't have time
to say oh we're going to wait for a
sunny day uh or we're going to wait for
a wintry day we shot everything in the
fall so the way we did it was that uh we
we would shoot a winter scene over here
and we would do some s and then suddenly
there was a guy we had a we had a person
looking at the guy going there's sun
coming and then we would like run over
while we ran Mass would change his
clothes and get ready for a summer scene
and we would walk over here and shoot a
lit just two images from that scene and
then oh sun is gone back to the winter
scene that was the craziest thing I've
ever but it was so much fun we had a lot
of fun doing that yeah yeah it's the
best fun it's the best energy uh because
you feel like a unit everybody's working
on the same project right uh but in in
in in general I mean besides being a
pain technically for a lot of
departments when the weather is crazy it
is a helping hand for the actor always
because we don't have to pretend it
anymore it's there there right so we
don't have to go whoa it's windy no it
is really
windy uh right there oh um I was
wondering just about your experience
co-writing the script with Andrew Thomas
Jensen I'm a really big fan of him and I
love the way you guys balance like
darkness and humor in the script so was
your experience like writing the script
with him and what was your experience
working off of that well I know of them
both very well uh funny enough some of
this stuff I was 100 sure anest Thomas
was writing some of the funny punchlines
and vice versa some of the more like
emotional stuff I got it completely
wrong it turned out that oh Nick wrote
that punchline that little joke and and
Thomas was going down a dark alley with
some emotions here so so they they rub
off on each other in a fantastic way
that surprises
you he's he's amazing he's he's a great
wrer this is the we've worked together
before but this is our first what feels
like our first real collab collaboration
true
collaboration uh and and he's he's
incredible and and what he brought to to
me was something that I hadn't been able
to what that I hadn't
been able to do or in my previous films
which was a really true sort of
emotional like he wrote a lot of the an
my moose you know lud scenes and I I
thought they were so beautiful and and
he's he's not he's unafraid of being
over ly emotional which I am a little
afraid of so it was great to have him
here and just push me and don't worry
it's it's fine you can always tone it
down if it gets too much I have a
question about um how you know sorry
asking question you worked with previous
directors a couple of different times
like I know right now there's
movie production um does that help you
decide what project you want to do or
just like okay this is a good story
I yeah it it's a combination I mean
let's put it this way if if Nick who I
wanted to work with again came up with
something I really
hated it it wouldn't have happened right
but but he of course he doesn't he comes
up with something that I find fantastic
and interesting I'm curious it's often
the case when you work with somebody
before that you really like
it's it's it's rarely going to happen
that it going to come up with something
that you dislike so so so even if you
kind of like it but you're not really
understanding it completely you're
willing to go there because you trust
them right so so I I I have been working
more than one time with a lot of people
and and for that reason because I I do
believe that the more comfortable you
are with each other the more you can
push each other uh and so so that's just
been my little safety net I guess
will you be attending any conventions in
the US that was great that was great
that's a good finish I I don't know and
that's a terrible answer but I don't
know it's always depending on if I'm
working or if I do have the time off or
um if there's something else I have to
do so I'm not sure at this point can I
do a followup to that yeah how many have
you done a lot of conventions I actually
don't know I've done a few in couple in
America few London and a few in Asia uh
I've been to Tokyo and soul a couple of
times and Osa is it something that you
enjoy is it something you know what I
mean it's overwhelming there's a lot of
love in the room when I say a lot it's a
lot H so so you just have to get ready
for that because it is fantastic and
beautiful but it's also exhausting but
but it's mean it's fantastic people get
a photo they get an autograph it's so
fast sometimes that you're ashamed of
yourself but it this is what it is when
uh when they do cons like that so it's
an overwhelming emotional experience so
but I do enjoy meeting all these people
on that note I'm going to say a few
quick things one validate two if you
enjoyed the movie there's this thing
called social media please uh mention
you know tag the film uh if you want to
tag collider or Landmark Theaters I'll
be more than happy to retweet you or
link you you know what I mean I want to
really help push the movie and on that
note ladies and gentlemen thank you for
coming out and let's give a warm Round
of
Applause thank you so
much